interesting the parties the main parties
seem to have pushed the roles of the
leaders wise even harder this campaign
christine has a veteran of that how do
you feel about the veteran thanks well
they're damned if they do and they're
damned if they don't the poor wives they
have to be trotted out they might not
like it and the three main leaders wives
this time they are all amazing women in
their own right they could all be out
there do they do are out there doing
their own thing outside the campaign but
I think they have to be there they kind
of they humanize the otherwise possibly
robotic politicians and I think a lot of
politicians need humanizing and the
wives do that they sort of offer the the
more intimate you know they give them
some femininity which they surely need
and but it must be a nightmare you know
how much did the top costume is that
where the shoes come from it is
ridiculous time what's the state of your
toenails oh well I know she'll never
live that down well she well we we're
talking about you know three fendi home
by women in their very high very high
flying ending and yet you say you know
we're talking about what they wear or
the state their toenails kind of right
but I'm sorry yeah I told it is it I
don't know if you look at this Nicholas
surgeons husband we don't focus on what
suit he wears we're not fussed about his
shoes should would be bothered and I
think it's all I think we do live in a
world now where we're almost I mean if I
seen Justine a blow like that dress I
wonder where she's got it from so in
some ways it's almost just just once
it's nobody got the dress from I'm not
interested in it whether it cost a
thousand pound a hundred pound or ten
pound but if it's a nice dressed and
then we all go out and buy you so yeah I
don't know I'm fairly relaxed about it
it's important if you're if you leave
for example if you'll Samantha Cameron I
think it's quite important to try and
get the image across you didn't buy your
dress from from goodness knows where you
actually did get was I mean yeah it's
anya we hadn't had that many bachelor
Prime Minister's we had of course Ted
Heath and mrs. Thatcher had a husband so
our spouses an asset liability just a
fact of life I mean I think they can be
an asset I mean I think they could be
much more of an asset in clementon for
instance was much more of a politician
supporting Winston Churchill than the
current crop are even though she
was seeing her job 70 years ago she was
much more involved in government much
more the public face of his his
government and she dealt with people's
problems she got unfold in so the
running of things a bit obviously during
the Second World War when circumstances
were excited and Denis Thatcher also is
is you know folk memories that he was a
steadying influence on Israel I think he
was definitely a steadying influence but
I don't think he was nearly as involved
as she was i'm in a way i'd like to see
politicians wise particularly leaders
wise be a little bit more ambitious i
didn't want to hear about their toenails
or kitchen is particularly I'm like what
do they think these women believe me
they have legalized debate but that's
not their fault is it that the media
focus on their turn I mean when you two
are on the screen together do they
really care what tired um is wearing
they do actually dress you're wearing
eyes debt and they don't want the focus
on it do there but if they pushed out in
the field like they've got to look good
they didn't it that thing to remember as
well though is it they're not
necessarily a public figure either so
they are the three successful women in
their own right very successful women so
they're just taking on this role of this
is my husband I'm supporting my husband
and crediton for doing that and I think
you know we do forget that the wife of
leaders it must be one of the most
hardest difficult jobs to actually do so
I respect to all three women and I
personally think they are three amazing
women their own route but you were right
we'd does anybody know anything about
mr. sturgeon or miss you Leanne wood or
mr. Green Party lady we don't and point
out you know I love all of them are in
defense of James I've seen profiles of
all of all those figures but then there
certainly is in the concentration or
what they look like she's probably just
as well no okay looking at the specific
choices we have before us Nick Clegg's
wife and the others who do you think
he's doing their husband the most credit
do I think probably Miriam is net
connect legs wife I think she goes out
there we see a bit of her intelligence
we see little bit of her her thinking
she went oh my goodness she escaped the
political minders for an evening the
other day and she disagrees with her
husband you know she believes in God she
says I'm not going to do
so I'm going to carry on working make it
a little more real it makes it more real
to me I mean I think she's actually done
him a lot of good and I think we'd all
like to see more though because I
interviewed her in the 2010 election
campaign when she will be following her
husband around and I said why aren't you
doing that I should come on I've got my
own job I've got my own but she still
not follow your husband no she's not but
she's doing woman she did then I think I
think people had a respect an amazing
role model I think you say she doesn't
necessarily agree with her husband
worked I think I'm sure you're the
historian Clemens at his wife voted
conservative all her life well I mean
pendulum Churchill was a liberal and
remained the netbook don't forget the
Tories had to put out an official
statement saying it was a foul slur to
suggest that Sam Cam might have voted
for Tony Blair okay so it was a but
it's interesting talking about kind of
teens robear I mean in this day of
social media Karen can politicians wives
afford to take that kind of role
nowadays I mean surely they'd be shot
down in flames if they were trying to
influence the way that what is what take
the role of being the mp's wife or take
the role of being being the real power
but I think so and I think that way
certainly for me and I have my role so
when I'm on duty am at the mp's wife you
know it's a very attentive job very very
seriously you know we got to various
events it's serious event you know
ceremonies of all descriptions but never
goes to fun events where people want me
to get Colombia I want me to have high
heels on and a nice dress because it'll
like that so I mean there's a slight
sense with with you to that you are sort
of miriam gonzales is that both of you
wear the trousers para- but I decide
which pair we put on I think it's the
important thing is that the spouses are
not thought necessary to be driving the
political agenda but of course I mean
pillow talk is about the most lethal
weapon that any spouse has got whether
it's denis thatcher or miriam gonzales
of course they influence their spouses
and I didn't really does tend to play to
their strengths so if I look you know
just in at the moment and it's such a
shame that justin hasn't come out sooner
because you've seen the today on screen
she's she's amazing it she's got that
empathetic approach and I can see that
she's a mom of two boys she's got boys
just a little younger than
and you naturally for me you have that
connection with it so I wish that
Justine came up sooner ela and I like
that kind of approach and I like
Miriam's approach that she's tough and
you won't tell me kind of wat suan I
like sons approached if she does always
seem to support David so it's three
incredible women were different yeah if
you found out where the politicians vote
for their wives anybody should date I'm
sure